good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy
tuesday we have such a special show for
you guys today because not only am i
joined
by my husband benjamin's offer boy with
no job the keto king hello
we are also joined by our son who
happens to be celebrating
his fourth birthday today so hello ben
hello mr
hello theo happy birthday you're welcome
how are you welcome to the show how are
you feeling are you nervous
let's talk never nervous absolutely
wonderful
4 20 the day of just sweet guns
the day of our son's birth and also
happy birthday to tan france
yes theo is birthday buddies with tan
france ben looked that up before thank
you for doing the research
that's why we love having you on the
show you always come prepared i'm very
research driven that is why you have me
i'm on to provide the facts you love the
database
and the facts only so it's theo's
birthday he's turning four yes
let's talk a little bit about what that
means four
is a year of growth yeah
four is a year of prosperity exploration
health prosperity did you say that
already yes
exploration yes he is increasingly more
and more off the leash
i'd say he's so independent like the
leash literally can't hold
him back nothing can no we were in
pennsylvania this weekend and he just
had a run of a
very large house and he ran that [ __ ] he
ran it
he ran it he ran out like a prison guard
so theo and i i mean ben and i would
like to wish theo
a happy happy happiest of birthdays
you're four years old 28 in dog years
but you'll always be a babe in our
hearts
and we love you theo thank you for being
such a great star of the show
a great son a great cousin a great
friend a great shoulder to lean on
he's he's everything everything and he
has a
sweet rump yeah and a big fat juicy ass
that is a rump okay i don't know what a
rump is rump is a booty
well theo's got a dump truck he does
back it up
so happy birthday theo if you want to
wish him a happy birthday feel free to
head over to his instagram account pups
with no job and leave
you know an inspiring message can we
talk about that account though
well because jackie's not here we can
ben has a lot of problems with the
management
of the dog's social media account it's
just [ __ ] up it's like
okay i understand that we got other
cavaliers in the family all of a sudden
theo has to share his instagram
that he worked so hard to get to seventy
four thousand followers imagine
for those who don't know the account
pups with no pup
pups with no job used to be pup with no
job it was just theo's account
um but when magnolia and bruno came into
the picture we're like oh we should just
have one account for all the dogs
why i'm just saying that's what happened
i needed to give people background do
you jackie and margo share an instagram
account
no and olivia do you guys all have one
no called girls with no job no
no you all have individual accounts one
is larger than the others because one
is uh carries some stuff on her back
theo
is that pup he carries the pups on his
back
he does but he builds his own brand but
that's the thing about the oh he's so
generous and so kind of
not like that he's not about ego which
clearly you are
on his behalf um that he doesn't mind
and if theo doesn't mind like why should
we
i think he minds no he doesn't he told
me you want to show me the paperwork
yeah no he signed over all the rights to
the instagram account years ago
okay fine um well we had a great weekend
we recapped a little bit with margo on
the show yesterday but we were like so
hungover
um tell us a little bit about your
weekend ben
my weekend my weekend was great we went
to pennsylvania
we hung out at brian kelly's house the
points guy i know you're all very
familiar with him
it was a wonderful time as always you
know filled with music fun
drinks little drag dogs dogs and drag
yes we went to drag brunch have you
you've been to drag before because like
you're always i've been to plenty of
dragons yeah because brian and i are
always going to drag but this was my
first time seeing drag i was telling
everyone yesterday
since watching drag race and really
appreciating the art it was also
a particularly good drag show it was it
was hysterical and
the performances were so funny and great
music it was really
a perfect sunday it was really really
great we also went to the casino
yeah friday night that was that was
crazy just crazy to be back
in a mask but it was totally fine it was
good um
it was good it wasn't good for everyone
it was good for me
i was the only one who who prevailed
yeah and won
um but you know casinos casinos are
great
they pump the oxygen your eyes are wide
open there's no windows you have no clue
what time it is
and you're just there like come on butts
when you go to a casino you become crazy
i become crazy yeah you do when we go to
a casino you say then
we you say ben you have bad energy i'm
not playing with it he does have bad
energy because you know why like
if the cards don't go our way you find a
way to blame it like well you weren't
smiling enough and it's like it's the
cards are the cards it's probability
it's math
so like when i feel like i'm in trouble
for the cards not working like
sometimes your energy's off sometimes
your energy is good
interesting that it's my energy that's
off when we split up
and i won and you lost which would make
one think that maybe it was actually
your energy
that was always off and not mine let me
rebuke that statement
we were all together you were by
yourself at the casino like
you so maybe everyone's energy is off
but mine
no we all really kind of came to the
conclusion that that night at the casino
was like rigged
so it was really like a you thing but
i'm really happy for you that you won
interesting i'm just saying like you are
the one whose energy is like sometimes
you're like so focused on energy that
you'll let
like you will ruin your sabotage your
own energy do you know what i'm saying
i do i do but overall i'm really glad
you won you know what's also sad
what and i knew this too i had one less
than i thought i did
of course like 100 because you don't
realize how much you take out you don't
realize how much you take out because
you're drunk you're having a good time i
was like oh [ __ ]
i want a thousand dollars and i'm like
actually i think i only won like 600.
yeah but that's great
no it's look anything over zero
is a win no even zero is a win push is a
win a break like what is it when you
break even like that's a wish
no like when you break even at the
casino to win you can move your
microphone a little closer to your mouth
yeah can people not hear me and they
just want to hear your sexy raspy voice
i understand is it raspy
um a little bit okay cool oh my god my
neck is so thrown out like i just like
cocked my head a little bit and i'm
gonna have to go to the hospital um we
have a great show for you guys today
warning there are like no stories but i
did choose
some things that are like slightly older
because i wanted to talk to you about
them
i didn't know if margo would give a [ __ ]
about them yesterday and i know that you
care about
them so our first stories about the jake
paul fight because i know you have like
a large conspiracy theory about it
sure and we're going to dive in if
that's okay with you of course
so uh without further a do
uh wait i never do this part
it is time for the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
ah what what the hell was that
me biting my toes no we have like a full
sound effect board
please do it again okay like no
no don't do that don't do that no don't
do it
today's episode is brought to you of
course by bruce the most fabulous
electric toothbrush on the market
that jackie and i have both been using
for months now every toaster has it if
you don't have the brush like you ain't
living
i use it too okay yes you do let me let
me do this okay
yeah no like this is the part where you
could just like chill you can check your
phone if you want that's fine okay
um yeah go for it so the brush
toothbrush has six unique modes to cut
six unique modes to customize your
brushing experience it comes with a four
week battery life a magnetic charging
stand and a compact travel case
they also offer a subscription program
so you never forget to change your brush
head again
bruce ships you new replacement heads
every six months so you're never stuck
using a worn down brush head
it comes in a sleek design their
electric toothbrush has a modern
aesthetically pleasing design
that comes in trend driven seasonal
colors and it looks great on your
bathroom counter
if you want to get 15 off your brush
toothbrush kit and refill plan
use the promo code toast at bruce.com
that's 15
off using promo code toast at bruce
b-r-u-u-s-h-dot-com
yes as you were saying we both have been
using the bruce and i had never used an
electric toothbrush before
and i'm having such a pleasant wonderful
fabulous experience
with the bruce and so are a million
toasters who've been using it so that's
bruce.com
promo code toast bruce bruce
okay so first story is something i chose
for you because i don't really care but
the world really seems to care
uh youtube star jake paul scores his
first round
knockout of ben askren in the third in
his third pro fight
so it took jake paul less than two
minutes to win his third professional
fight
the youtube star turned boxer sent ben
askren
into the canvas with a straight right
hand midway through the first round of
their first cruiserweight fight on
saturday
even though ashford got up the referee
brian stutz
called the fight at a minute and 59
seconds inside the mercedes-benz stadium
in atlanta
paul who's now 3-0 then collapsed to the
canvas in tears
before celebrating and doing push-ups in
the ring the 24-year-old paul took care
of ascrine quickly paul was patient for
the first minute while ascerine chased
him around the ring
then as paul began to get comfortable he
made a quick work of the 36 year old
asgren
paul set up and then straight right with
a jab and the solid contact
sent asgrin down after the fight paul
climbed up into the broadcast booth to
celebrate with snoop dogg
he said it's been four months i've been
trained in training camp every day paul
said on triller after the fight
i deserve that [ __ ] this is the craziest
moment of my life i told y'all i was
gonna do it in the first round i told
y'all i'm a real fighter
i don't know how many times i've got to
prove myself this this is for real
okay so i did think it was actually
crazy uh the first time paul
jake paul won against nate robinson
but why did we think that that was crazy
because uh
jake paul is like i think and it's clear
that he's struggling to be taken
seriously and i definitely can see how
that is because like
i feel like he's just like every he
there's just like a jokey vibe about him
like everything's a joke you know
no i i get that but like when you are he
he looks like he's at least six two he
clearly
does box and work out he's clearly
strong
when you put yourself in a ring when
you're he takes boxing more seriously
than
everybody that he's ever competed with
he's playing like he's fighting against
guys because he's something
he has something to prove no but they
also aren't boxers like it's the
equivalent of
what was nate robinson and yeah he
played for the knicks
okay like so that one is not ben askren
was an mma fighter who is
was bad when he was in the mma and has
never boxed before
okay so now can you talk about why you
you told me
that you thought it was rigged i thought
that it was rigged because you just said
ben askren's not even good
no but i but he was he still got up
like oh oh yeah when you box
and somebody knocks you to the ground
especially if it's in the first round
and the person gets back up that quickly
the fight is not just called
the ref called the fight it was over it
was awarded to jake paul ben askren was
totally fine
well he wasn't fine but he did stand up
he was totally fine but don't the
referees call it for like people's
safety
yeah but they also have their personal
discretion to call it when they want to
so are you saying that the referee brian
had a personal discretion
for jake paul like he was perhaps you
know
bribed i'm saying that there is no way
that any fight that jake paul does with
triller
that is sponsoring youtubers and tick
tocks to fight
is going to award an mma fighter
over a tick-tock youtube star i'm saying
i feel like triller really wants to be
like serious in the game and you can't
be
you can be taken seriously if you're
rigging stuff
they don't want to be taken seriously in
the game because that was like the
saddest
pay-per-view fight of all time and it's
oh that's the other thing like
entertainment-wise it's like we're all
sitting around for hours like
but we went to bed at like 12 30 and it
still wasn't
it still wasn't on it still wasn't on so
it's like you make everyone wait around
for
hours and then they get a minute and 59
seconds of a fight when people pay you
to pay 70 dollars when people pay for
fights on pay-per-view they're paying
for a full card
yeah the card consists of like all right
fights but the chick paul one was like
the most
like famous one of course but there were
no other fights oh there weren't no
there were no other fights it was just
musical acts it was bieber it was oh
that's cool charlie and dixie dominion
what i'm saying is that it's a show i'm
not sure haley and dixie performed no
they like handed him his
belt oh like i'm not saying that it's
even if it's not rigged rigged is the
wrong word
it's performative the same way that the
wwe
is not rigged it's a show no the wwe
is it's fake it's fake but i think that
this also is
fake okay that's interesting i also feel
like jake paul is so desperate to be
taken seriously that he wouldn't get
involved in something that's rigged
because if people even think that it's
rigged like he's he's so hell-bent on
being taken seriously like as a
boxer no i think that he's just
hell-bent on having a career as
something that
isn't isn't a youtuber that it's
something he can say
i'm a boxer and also all of a sudden we
forgot that he
was arrested for having firearms in his
car so
all of a sudden all this [ __ ] goes away
arrested he was raided by the fbi which
is even worse
he's i'm just saying like all of a
sudden he was like known as like the
biggest
drug dealer yeah there were all these
conspiracy all this [ __ ] and all of a
sudden he becomes a monster boxer
and like you're right it's changed the
director of his career it's the pr move
of the century
it is so you stand by that you think the
whole thing was like
perf like rehearsed i think so okay
i do that's no shade no i do think i
think that he
he clearly is like a skilled fighter
no i do picking guys i do think that
there's something there
yeah um about like the whole like the
demilio's giving him the the bell like
that's [ __ ] weird
the whole thing is it's but the whole
thing was also really legit like there
was snoop dogg pete davidson justin
bieber like
yeah so it happens when you have a tech
valuation and you raise so much money
it's triller you just chuck money at
people
yeah it's just it's a show
yeah i don't know i just like i really
want it to be real
okay um well thank you for your insight
on that
i do think maybe you made some decent
points none of it is based in fact
no no of course but it's just a feeling
and that's what we do here at the
morning toast we talk about our feelings
i got a feeling i got a feeling
[Music]
all right next story uh james charles
update youtube
his youtube channel has been temporarily
demonetized amid sexual misconduct
allegations
on friday april 16th both james charles
and morphy issued a statement about
ending their business relationship
um read more about why they're parting
ways so
there's two things going on here let me
give you a little bit of background
please
uh james charles is being accused of
like grooming sexting minors
he made a video on it and explained like
there have been a few people in the last
year who have come forward and said like
james charles was texting me and
appropriately snapchatting me
inappropriately when i was 16.
james charles made a video and said he
the people who have come out against him
like he has spoken to them but he had
asked them if they were 18 and they lied
and said yes
so that was his defense but since that
video came out there's just been like
more people more snapchats more evidence
and it's just like really weird like why
are so many 16 year olds coming out of
the woodwork saying they've had
inappropriate conversations with james
charles
it's very bizarre so it's clear that his
youtube video explaining himself like
did him no favors
because morphe which is you know you
know morpheus
no it's like a huge makeup company
that's really built off the back of like
influencers and stuff and he made a
palette with them and um
eyeshadow palette that's like one of
their most popular products ever it was
a collab but it like is sold in every
store it's like international bestseller
morphe and james charles mutually
decided to part ways on friday
morphy shared an announcement on twitter
saying
in light of the recent allegations
against james charles morphy and james
charles have agreed to end business
relationships and wind down the sales of
the morphe x james
charles product offering which is crazy
because that's like one of their most
popular palettes
they said it is it is and always has
been morphe's goal to create a positive
safe and empowering space
where all beauty lovers can freely share
their artistry and passion for cosmetics
and morphe is committed to that goal so
that happened on friday and then
a youtube spokesperson released a
statement we can confirm that we had
applied our creator responsibility
policy and temporarily removed james
charles
from the youtube partner program so
according to a video from youtube
creators liaison matt koval
the company has the right to demonetize
content from a creator if they deem
their actions to be reckless
dangerous or inappropriate on or off the
platform
it's unclear how long the makeup uh it's
unclear how long james charles's channel
will be demonetized so i just thought
this was crazy because
i don't can't really think can't really
recall a scenario in which a platform
has kind of
intervened in a creator's like scandal
it's really [ __ ] up what is that
youtube demonetizes channel
when there isn't a what were we going to
say
they did it to david dobrik and dom 2
amidst their allegations
wait why is it [ __ ] up it's [ __ ] up
because we need to just
let the the law say that what happened
actually happens am i wrong i think that
it's sort of like saying that
i'm not saying that he's not guilty but
you can take away his privileges when
he's
when he's guilty but to make it so that
he can no longer make any money when
maybe it's not true no you might not
have enough context that's the worst
take ever like you've ever had
okay here's the thing there's there's
how old was he
this year this year it happened who
cares how old he is i thought he was 18
years old
no he's like 21 and he's texting miners
like sending them really inappropriate
snapchats like
he that's i think this was like a good
call by youtube like you don't want to
be associated with people
who are grooming minors i don't have
enough context on the story
you know that was a really bad take i i
still don't think so but it's fine
well the thing is is like when it comes
to
youtubers like youtube is such an
integral part of their success and like
they literally
without the collaborations without like
the fame they're making if you have a
big channel like
20 million dollars a year in adsense
yeah so i think like youtube has a lot
of power and i think it sends a powerful
message to be like no
this type of behavior like we don't [ __ ]
with illegal
grooming minors activity okay i agree
with you
i'm just saying that i if he did that
then yeah
it's [ __ ] up yeah but until people
then you should go to jail agreed okay
so let them say that but so
like you know what i'm saying yeah but
like there there is
definitive proof like you could see it
everywhere is definitive proof oh yeah
screen recordings snapchats
like screenshots so then sorry but you
[ __ ] up
yeah no i think this is like the right
thing to do on youtube's part a hundred
percent
bad take but i'm glad we got we served
you the right way i don't i don't know
if it's a bad take you can't
like if you're asking me questions and i
don't have full context i'm gonna give
you
the way that i feel which is that you
are innocent until proven guilty
like you are but in in cases of like
sexual harassment and assault we believe
the victims so
of course i do so james charles no okay
no james charles now james charles now
cool this is a big no
and i've been a fan of james charles i
feel like i've even defended him like in
his dumb ass [ __ ] like
drama that's like nonsensical you know
but this is not like stupid drama this
is like really serious
so we uh we'll keep you abreast on all
things going on
in the james charles world i won't no
you certainly won't you will
um and i'm going to dive into some more
stories but letting you know that they
are brought to you by liquid iv
liquid iv's hydration multiplier plus
immune support is a cutting-edge blend
of vitamin c
zinc and wellmune in convenient single
serving packets to help strengthen your
immune system
vitamin c is well known to help and
protect your body and support good
health
zinc the second most abundant trace
mineral in your body supports immune
cell health and function
wellmune is a naturally sourced beta
glucan that's proven to help strengthen
your immune system
where each packet is bursting with fresh
natural tangerine flavors it tastes
so good liquid iv provides two to three
times more hydration than water alone
so i love these liquid iv supplements
because i'm not great at drinking water
and also just like
i don't feel like i'm really like
balanced in my nutrients so if you can
just use a
packet of liquid iv in a bottle of water
and it does multiple things for your
body
you feel good you look good it's really
helpful
and there's a great science behind
liquidity with their cellular transport
technology which is designed
to enhance rapid absorption of water and
other nutrients so i feel like when i
drink water sometimes it just like goes
right through me you know it doesn't
like
do anything liquid iv ensures that it
does all their products taste really
good they come in tons of flavors
and summer's around the corner you gotta
stay hydrated you know it's getting hot
out there
get your liquid iv hydration multiplier
plus immune support in bulk at costco
or order online and get 25 off when you
go to liquidive.com
and use the code toast at checkout
that's 25 off anything you order
when you get better hydration today
using promo code toast at liquid iv.com
again promo code toast liquid ivy.com
i love costco keeping up me too what a
store
you actually no i don't sorry i wasn't
even listening to what you're saying i
hate [ __ ] costco
which is crazy yeah um in a little bit
more youtube news
jeffrey starr says he has to wear back
brace for a few months after a car crash
in wyoming have you been keeping up with
this at all
no okay youtuber jeffrey stark flipped
his car
three times on monday morning after
hitting black ice in casper wyoming
he has left the hospital with a broken
back after he and his friend were in a
car accident
the 35 year old youtube star shared a
video update on his instagram story
saturday
he's 35. i thought he was older actually
i think i did too
so they were hospitalized friday morning
and he said i leave the hospital today i
have to wear this crazy brace for a few
months
so basically they were like a really bad
car accident like they
their car flipped over a bunch of times
him and his friend daniel
and they've been sharing a lot of
content from the uh
hospital and i've seen like a lot of
really interesting like
feedback from uh the community on
jeffree star i think a lot of people are
like
first of all a lot of people are being
really mean because they don't like
jeffree star i'm like making fun of him
which is like really
not nice because like the person was in
a car accident like let's be cool but
also
um he's just like sharing a lot of like
content from the hospital and people are
like
it's making a lot of people i've been
seeing on twitter like think that he's
lying like about this whole accident
like him and his friend daniel are doing
like lemur skincare in their hospital
beds
and so people are making fun of the
content and thinking that he's making
this whole thing up
but he's like in the hospital yeah that
would be [ __ ] crazy
i don't think that he's making it up
that being said talk about getting out
easy a broken back after the car flips
three times he could be dead no i know
and
in the video he i'm sure he's wearing
makeup but he looks like he doesn't have
any bruises
both him and daniel but his friend
daniel has survived colon cancer three
times
so his internal um like injuries are
worse and he's like being flown to like
a special hospital to get like surgery
wow so it's really serious no but that
guy is has nine lives no i know he's
like that guy what was that guy from was
it game of thrones
which one the one that could never die
jon snow
no the hound no you need to give me
something like more
he was more he was with the like in
those scenes with the red woman
he would like come out with like one
like weird eye like nine months
i don't know his name but yes i know
what you're talking about yeah that was
like a really specific
um reference like unnecessary yeah
but um so yes a lot of people think that
he's faking this because his content has
been like
kind of extreme in the hospital but i
just feel like that's jeffrey like he's
so
extra yeah do you want to add anything
you picked stories that i'm not going to
add anything to i don't know what the
hell you want for me oh my gosh first i
give my
i give my opinion without having the
right amount of context on james charles
and now i seem like the bad guy but i
just didn't have full context
now we're talking about jeffree star do
i think that he fakes this car accident
for clout probably not because he's
the richest person on the planet and
doesn't need anybody's clout
i agree thank you that's what i was
asking for cool
okay all right next story uh what is it
oh
this one i think you actually might like
from page six kim kardashian is being
courted by royals
billionaires and a-listers amid divorce
shocking
kim kardashian is earning the title of
most eligible billionaire bachelorette
following her split from kanye west
a source told us the kkw beauty ceo is
being courted
by the cream of the crop from potential
suitors quote people are reaching out
their mutual friends and people that
she's worked with to set her up with
everyone from royal family members
to a-list actors to athletes to
billionaire ceos
people are also trying to reach out to
her via dm although she's being flooded
with a bevy of dating options we're told
the student to be single mom is not
looking for anyone right now
she's not looking to jump into anything
but keeping an open mind a source said
while a source previously told us that
kardashian's estranged husband kanye
west wants to date an artist
in the next chapter of his life the
keeping up with the kardashian star is
not on the hunt to date anyone in any
specific field
so i thought this was interesting and
obviously it makes sense like kim is
eligible for a multitude of reasons like
she's gorgeous she's stunning she's
smart she's a billionaire but i kind of
love the idea of her being with like a
a royal yeah i i'm interested to see
who and when she does
pick it pick a suitor if she does
because this is the first time
in her career where i don't i genuinely
don't think that she
feels that she needs anyone yeah no
that's a really good point
nobody like throughout her career like
did she love chris humphries who knows
uh like i assume that she did but there
have been like a lot of
reasons why maybe she dates a basketball
player or she dates
like whoever it is
a rising star 100 strategic and maybe
the kanye ones started off as strategic
but it then turned into clearly they
were
in love and have so many kids whatever
now she is just like
so successful so untouchable completely
on top
i just like i feel like maybe she like
it would make sense if she dated
somebody that wasn't famous
like maybe she just found somebody like
a businessman like she loved that like
was
sort of off the grid because she doesn't
need she doesn't need somebody else's
clout she doesn't need any more
well she doesn't need it but at the end
of the day when you are the level of
fame that kim is which is like something
astronomical most normal people
won't ever even understand you want
someone who gets that lifestyle
no i understand i'm just she doesn't
need it for work like there are plenty
of
super super super super powerful people
who aren't famous no i'm saying super
powerful people that are married to
people
that aren't famous yes i agree but i
think
a lot of that the times that that's the
situation like they came up together
sometimes so like mark wahlberg's wife i
always think it's like she's she's not
famous
but they've been together forever he
didn't meet her at the height of his
fame
who's oprah married to stedman when did
they get married like forever
forever ago also not oh yeah right
they're not married they're just like in
a long-term
relationship partnership so maybe it's a
bad call by me i don't know you're right
like she doesn't need it but it would be
uh like nice for her to date someone who
like gets the lifestyle
yeah um who i don't know
i know like i kind of see her not with
him because we hate him now but like an
a-rod type
someone who's like a a super mega
retired athlete
that's cool who's the guy you would've
been cool who's an a-rod type but she's
found a j-lawsuit whenever and also a
rod hugs
derek jeter married uh
doesn't have to be baseball but actually
i think baseball like is good
retired a-list would work
he can't be too old no like 50s
hmm i don't know okay thanks
i'll think about it and come back okay
yeah i just thought it was interesting
and
remember when rihanna was dating that
like i think he was like a prince in
saudi arabia who's like a billionaire
that's the kind of energy kim needs like
someone who can keep up with her
lifestyle
and not only that like support her i
feel like kim's been putting her entire
family on her back for years like maybe
someone can help alleviate some of her
back pain
or maybe she can just realize that she
has a lot of money and doesn't need to
work as hard as she does
no but when you like that's true she has
a lot of money
now their lifestyle is so expensive to
maintain like she
she can't stop like with the kids and
the homes and the planes like
you can't just you have a lot of money
but like that runs out when your
life expenses are so high i understand
so you got to keep that hustle
i don't know who's right for her me
neither she's like too powerful
she is really really powerful i don't
even know we need like a
david beckham type maybe it's a soccer
player yeah maybe it's like
victoria to her david no the david to
her victoria maybe it's like
a neymar or uh i don't know who i don't
know if any of these guys are married
yeah but who knows what about like a
like a bad bunny is he married oh that's
so funny that you say that because
she was spotted out in miami i think
with maluma
and a lot of people were like wondering
if that was that's so funny that you
said that
um he maintains that he's single but i
think maybe they were like flirting or
whatever but i agree i thought that was
a good match too yeah like a
a monster monster international
pop star like a singer yeah singer you
know i thought that's very interesting
as well
i believe it was maluma who she was
spotted out with but yes
i see that for her as well someone with
an international name because she is so
internationally recognizable
she is where what airport did we get off
at and we saw her ad
what oh we were in israel and we saw her
carolina lemke
sunglasses at it's crazy like yes just
to see her
in like somewhere so random yes crazy
you know she has that like
global recognizable name and like she
needs someone who has the same
yep she does i would beg to beg to argue
that she's more globally recognizable
than kanye
she definitely is yeah she definitely is
now i'm trying to think like who who
else it could possibly be
no i know it's like there are very few
people that are on that level like
athletes right
it can only be a soccer player there is
no like nfl player that's on that level
is cristiano ronaldo uh dating anyone
yeah he's married oh but he's
yeah so just something to think about
when you lay your head on your pillow at
night
um i think our fit and final story which
i think is something i
hope you'll like because it's about food
um is brought to you by paint your life
if you want to give your wife
grandmother parents someone the perfect
birthday gift wedding gift or
anniversary gift
then you have to discover paint
yourlife.com you can get a professional
hand-painted
portrait created from any photo at a
really affordable price
you choose from a team of world class
artists and work with them every
until every detail is perfect you have a
user-friendly platform that lets you
order a custom-made hand-painted
portrait in less than five minutes
so you guys know me and ben are obsessed
with our shrine to theo
and one of our handmade paintings is
from paint your life and it's so
stunning it's such a nice gift it's also
great just if you want to get something
for yourself
whether it's for a dog a family photo
it's up to you
you can send any picture of yourself
your children your family a special
place a pet
or you can you can combine photos into
one painting
it makes a perfect birthday gift
anniversary gift or a wedding gift it's
really meaningful personal and it can be
cherished forever
so we had such a fabulous experience
with painterlife.com and every time i
show a picture of my wall on my
instagram a lot of people ask where we
commissioned that painting from
paintyourlife.com at paintyourlife.com
there's no risk if you don't love the
final painting your money is refunded
guaranteed and right now as a limited
time offer you can get 20
off your painting that's right 20 off
and free shipping to get the special
offer text the word morning to six four
zero zero zero
that's morning to six four zero zero
zero text morning to six four zero zero
zero
paint your life celebrate the moments
that matter most terms apply available
at paint your life dot com
slash terms again text morning to six
four zero zero zero
all right we got some food news from
mcdonald's their new bt
their new bts meal is coming i heard
about this it's featuring flavors you
aren't able to get in the u.s
so mcdonald's is partnering with bts the
massively popular korean pop band for
its next celebrity meal
and this time it's going global the
aptly titled bts meal goes on sale may
26 in the u.s
canada and brazil and soon after in
nearly 50 countries spanning contingents
and consists of
spanning six oh sorry literally can't
speak
spanning six continents and it consists
of the super star band's signature order
the company announced on monday the meal
includes a 10-piece chicken nugget
medium fries and coke as well as the us
debut of two new dipping sauces
sweet chili and cajun flavors inspired
by
mcdonald's south korean recipes the
burger chain said partnering with bts is
arguably mcdonald's biggest
get yet following the smash success of
its meals with jay balvin and travis
scott so
i am obsessed with international
mcdonald's like you and i went to
mcdonald's in israel and they did the
craziest [ __ ] of course it's also kosher
so we were able to have like burgers
but what else did we get that like we
had never seen on a menu before
they had like hummus they had like
schnitzel yeah it was so good it was
really good
the only thing that i'll say because i
heard about this story already
that's not like uh that's [ __ ]
chicken nuggets
there's nothing special wow two sauces
no but that's what these celebrity meals
are it's like
it's exactly what travis said j belvin
and bts order
so you can just like order what they
order it's not like that like it's not
that creative of a business idea yeah
but
it's just like kind of a crack of [ __ ]
like yeah like i could order just like a
ten piece
you know a lot of 10 piece nuggets and
two sides of sauces like
i understand of course the marketing
move like like i get it but like
you could give like uh i don't know like
a souvenir
uh dish that like your nuggets come in
they like have
their faces on it like yeah if people
are going in like the amount of money
that mcdonald's generated from the
travis scott meals yeah
and from the who would you say was the
other one that did it uh jay balvin
like this bts meal is going to blow
up everyone's going to water it but this
bts meal is literally what i get when i
go but that's what i'm trying to say
it's like isn't they can't like step it
up a little
no i know give some give the people
something and also two new sauces like
when mcdonald's internationally like
serves
i've been on tick tocks where people are
eating mcdonald's like in france and
they get like such different [ __ ] than
us
and it looks so good like give us some
of that there's also sweet chili and
sweet and sour like very similar yeah
and like a sweet cajun like you don't
think we have there's like
there's like buffalo sauce what the hell
is the difference no totally it's the
same [ __ ]
it's a little bit underwhelming you're
right it's fine i'm just saying like
mcdonald's could do a little bit more
considering they're generating
probably a billion dollars off of this
partnership with yeah i think this will
be huge it's like
it should be huge bgs i'm actually such
a big bts fan you are
we love dynamite i love dynamite when
they first like started getting played
on
like radio and stuff i did not
understand like the hype i'm fully
understood on the hype now yeah they're
cool yeah the only thing that i don't
understand is how do any of them make
money
i know because there's so many of them
there's ten but they also generate so
much money but i feel like it's kind of
like a fifth harmony situation
where like these bands in in the k-pop
industry like there's so many bands and
they generate so much money but they're
part of this big company i watched a
documentary about the black pink girls
they're part of like uh it's like this
machine
that generates all these different pop
stars and i feel like
they kind of have a raw deal i don't
know that for sure that's just like the
vibe that i got i mean
they automatically have a raw deal
because they have to split it seven
seven ways
but they're also making more money than
any band like
you can't even compare it like they're
global superstars
yeah i guess they're probably not like
like i would argue that they're just as
big like maybe bigger this is going to
be crazy than like the beatles
um it's not crazy because distribution
is so different and music is so much
more accessible
and streams are so much easier to come
by like right aside from bts bts is
great
in general music is completely dead like
the music industry is dead i don't know
if we want to talk about this now
what do you mean i mean anybody can get
it's all based off streams
yeah like if you get a lot of streams
you are considered a famous musician you
can start to go and tour and do all
these things
like the fact that like a dixie demilio
can become
uh a successful pop star and addison ray
uh like i just i just don't think that
the integrity of music is there anymore
and i think that
people are or at least mainstream or
gravitating more towards these like
made in a lab by like shitty musician
songs versus there's so many
like like rocks
no i don't think the integrity of the
music industry is gone i think that
the a r industry is gone like the way
you used to be traditionally discovered
like you would have to send a demo like
when you hear taylor swift talk about
like her rise to fame she would drop off
copies of her demo at every label in
nashville of course that's correct so a
r is completely gone i don't think the
music industry is gone because at the
end of the day if a song is bad it
doesn't do well
it's just that's just not true though
and say what you want about like dixie
demilia but like that song is good
no it's not good sometimes i don't wanna
be
happy see you've been tricked no i like
that song
okay but it's bad so is obsessed you say
you're obsessed
with me so i took a second and i said me
too
that's a terrible song as much
just because you think it's terrible
doesn't mean that it's terrible no
because you know that i have a very
wide range i'm able to accept that so
many different forms of music are good
but can't you accept the fact that you
might have aged out of the music that's
popular right now
no like it's not that it's bad it's just
that you're too old
no i'm stubborn i can't i think that's
because when we were younger
we listened to pop we listened to rap we
listened to what our parents gave us
right like
we were like i was at least obsessed
with rock and like all that stuff
like that [ __ ] doesn't exist anymore
yeah
the millennial parents that are giving
[ __ ] to their kids or whoever whoever is
obsessed with that stuff are they
millennials
who obsessed with what saying like the
the the mid 30s
no the 40 year old parent with like the
15 year old kid
is that a millennial 40 i don't
understand the question
gen x oh they're like boomers boomers
it's not boomers though wait what are
you talking about
my parents are born i did phase out like
a little bit when you were going on and
on about like the whole parents thing so
start again
okay i was saying that my parents
introduced me
to classic songs billy joel
whoever yeah yeah rolling stones yeah
etc rock on now
who are the parents introducing telling
the kids to listen to
that they like dixie dimillio i don't
think that most parents are trying to
force their music i think you grew up in
a house like
that was unique oh really i think
interesting like the kids like mom like
let me listen to my ipod you know like
i don't think that that's a thing
but i don't know who it would be so i
disagree with you but that's fine that's
fine that's what we do here at the
morning toast we disagree
ben i hope you enjoyed your time here i
did ramble down a bit
no it's good we live for it that's this
is the morning tangent that's what we do
is there anything you want to talk about
before we let everyone go like any
updates on your life
like your hair is long um like
everything's good all that i'm gonna say
is that we're gonna have a really crazy
summer
i know i'm so excited we have something
really really really exciting
and like be prepared like this is
exactly what happened this week like
be prepared for us to take a weekend
away and like never come back you know
like that's exactly what happened at
the at brian's this weekend
oh totally yeah like trips galore no but
that's not what i was talking about oh i
was saying there's something crazy
happening this summer
big time like you guys are going to go
crazy you guys it has been an absolute
pleasure hanging out with you this
morning
truckers for banner have arrived thank
god thank you for being here thank you
for your time i know how busy you are
thank you darling thank you for being a
great father to theo and a good husband
to me
yes of course thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning testimonial
morning show where we deliver the fast
life stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching us on youtube please
don't forget to subscribe give this
video a thumbs up
we're also available in the podcast and
we're podcasting we found spotify itunes
stitcher public radio i already catch
box all the places
so wherever you listen to podcasts find
us morning tell sleepy five star review
about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are hope you have
an amazing day and we will see you guys
tomorrow for
hump day goodbye